decreasing my need for marijuana and
increasing money for other things that
you know we're not so positive you know
things like opiates and benzodiazepines
and and and alcohol in combination in
concert yeah it's not the best yeah and
especially if you like around the early
2000s you could get whatever you wanted
online you know they weren't really
regulating anything and you could sort
of get whatever drug you wanted
including things you know like replicate
replicates of quaaludes that they're
making in India things that have no
medicinal value you know at least for
whatever it's worth there were some
traits of like certain prescription
drugs that I guess would have I guess
we're of some assistance like xanax or
percocet but you know like you don't
abuse them you certainly don't take them
with alcohol
yeah yeah so I just did a lot of that
kind of stuff yeah I missed that boat
yeah I got sober in the early 2000s and
you told me that when we had we were
eating at Greenblatt's one night about
the internet it was just like I could
have died and maybe because I had or
does this guy named Paul vato and he's
as fat Mexican dude who he's a second
city guy very talented very funny guy
but I would have to he would get I don't
know how he got it but he would come to
my house with like 200 vicodins who end
up in a bag though yeah you know and he
would just hand it to me I'd give him
money and then sometimes he would be on
the road I couldn't get any so I had to
resort to other things but I if I would
have had the internet I don't know you
don't know how to use a computer though
thank God what do you mean we were at
Best Buy yesterday and I said open a new
folder oh he doesn't know like basic
yeah iPad and smartphone he you're like
Hillary [ __ ]
berries right we have a staff member by
those antiquated blackberries because
she didn't know how to do anything else
right right not even like a desktop well
that's what the email stuff was about
because of her ignorant of Technology
right so they just kind of will just
didn't know they were doing it what's it
what is worse that she is let me just
say this I would be able to [ __ ]
figure it out yeah I mean it's like it's
like you say that you say that I'm I
wouldn't be able to figure it out I
would call somebody good how do you do
it well go Duncan come to my house get
me vicodin he would do it she provokes
me you get mad get mad you can't get mad
no I love her no I'm not he's a pretty
occasion she he only pretends to get mad
around people but he never gets me I've
never been mad I mean she bought
sometimes says things that are
bothersome bothersome things you know
but I swallow we've been together long
enough to where it's like everything
just like yesterday yesterday we were I
was smoking a cigarette outside huh I
put it out mmm I blew out the rest of
the smoke out of my mouth
Yeah right then I walk in the car and
she you're trying to kill me huh would
you say that that's not what I said you
brought the cigarette in with you yeah
oh yeah you can't smoke around her oh
well you okay I smoke though no she's
defending that's good no my best friend
smokes but she's so considerate about
yeah where she is around me I will never
do
[Laughter]
[Music]